crypto Armageddon is here the biggest
players in the world are at War they're
fighting it out and I'm here to tell you
who won and what's next now I'm gonna be
honest I called this yesterday I warned
you guys that FTX second largest
exchange might be insolvent and people
called me crazy they said no way the guy
who described all of defy as a Ponzi
scheme could be bad Sam bankman freed
he's just too smart FTX after all is
endorsed by Tom Brady what could go
wrong with another celebrity endorsement
people like Larry David backed FTX
surely your funds are safe Well turns
out they were actually in danger all
along and things are looking very bad so
I'm gonna explain to you this entire
mess very quick but bear in mind this is
a very Dynamic situation things are
changing by the hour but let's get into
it
once there existed two rival crypto
exchanges binance and FTX the number one
and number two crypto exchanges and
their CEOs CZ and SBF or Sam bankman
freed hate each other that's an
important part of this story but things
were calm at first for the most part
they played nice for years until
recently SBF decided to take a pot shot
at his competitor's attempts to work
with regulators and said uh he is
allowed to go to DC right implying that
CZ was banned now he didn't know it at
the time but SBF set off World War III
in crypto with this tweet and he might
have signed his own funeral because a
few days later a report came out from
coindesk leaking ftx's Financial balance
sheet and what it showed is that they
had a lot of money but it was sort of
locked up in all these token projects
they were a part of most notably in ftt
token Solana and other projects that
they were behind and they couldn't sell
the projects anytime they wanted to in
other words even though they had
billions of dollars worth of assets they
weren't very liquid and it was arguable
that some of the coins weren't that
valuable so they couldn't get access to
these funds immediately meanwhile they
had huge liabilities of 8 billion
dollars 7.4 billion of which were loans
now Dirty Bubble media who was the
person who caught out the collapse of
Celsius which we've talked about
extensively picked this up in a scathing
report in it he suggested that FTX and
Alameda research might be insolvent
because all their money was locked up in
these tokens that might be worthless and
if everyone tried to withdraw their
money all at once the company could
likely not pay off their liabilities now
CZ saw this and decided to take an
opportunity to strike against his
biggest rival he announced that day that
because of recent Revelations which
because of that report quote we have
decided to liquidate any remaining ftt
on our books now this was massive given
that FTI X's number one holding was ftt
their competitor binance is saying that
they're going to dump up to 2.1 billion
dollars worth of it on the open market
causing that price to plummet now all of
a sudden you don't even have E-liquid
funds you just have none of those funds
so even though CZ said that this was not
a move against a competitor it kind of
looked like it was right of course he's
going to say that in reality he knew
what he was doing now immediately this
stoked all sorts of fears about the
solvency of FTX and the fear spread like
wildfire is FTX the next Luna is FTX the
next Celsius and people started to
withdraw funds like crazy which honestly
was The Logical move to make the problem
with crypto exchanges right now is that
because there's no monetary Insurance on
your money even if the probability of an
exchange going bust is less than one
percent you still have to take all your
money out because if they do go bus you
lose everything if it doesn't go bust
you only lose a fraction of on trading
fees for being cautious and so there's
really nothing to risk by taking your
money out and there's everything to risk
by keeping it in so basically that means
Bank runs are extremely common these
days and a lot of these exchanges
they're really not ready for it in fact
Sam bankman freed himself said that a
lot of crypto exchanges are secretly
insolvent uh which was a bit of weird
foreshadowing but at first it looked
like FTX wouldn't go and solve and a lot
of people said this was very unlikely
since in the past they've looked very
strong and that's what they basically
said they said look it's no big deal
this is all fun nothing to worry about
Alameda research who is closely tied to
FTX actually responded about these uh
leaks in their financial balances and
they said quote they have 10 billion
dollars worth of assets that aren't
reflected there and that also they have
returned most of their loans by now and
most shocking of all was that they
offered CZ to buy all of his ftt off
market for 22 each near the current
price price now the reason for this is
obviously to show that okay we're not
scared we've got the money to back this
up and if you really aren't trying to
sink us as a competitor you'll be happy
to do this private deal get a better
price and not impact our price it would
save both parties a lot of headache but
unsurprisingly because these guys hate
each other CZ wasn't having it he said
he was going to stay in the free market
signaling that he fully intended to
squash the price of ftt and he did ftt
dropped over the next 24 hours 30
percent and not only that reports
started showing that FTX withdrawals
were increasing the bank run really was
happening like CZ wanted and this is
where we have to go back to alameda's
CEO what they said about having 10
billion dollars worth of assets
because there's some really key caveats
about those claims what are those 10
billion dollars worth of assets are they
cash because if they are they're
probably fine but if there's something
like more ftt token or more of Sam's
other projects that he can't sell well
that's going to be a significant problem
for them when everybody's running and
asking for their crypto back and they
just don't have it so questions were
flying about what exactly FTX was doing
with your money when you deposited it
were they just giving it to Alameda
research which is sort of acting like a
hedge fund and trading with your crypto
trying to make a big return or were they
keeping your funds safe and just
practicing proper risk management well
this is where everyone just basically
waited with baited breath to see what
was going to happen next uh oh this
looks pretty bad they froze withdrawals
and at the same time the team basically
went totally silent and people commented
on how bad this looks on them why aren't
they speaking and people started to
Circle back to old clips of Sam bankman
free describing defy and crypto as
basically a Ponzi scheme positively and
they wondered how did any of us trust
this guy I think of myself as like a
fairly cynical person and yep that was
so much more cynical yeah I would have
described farming like you're just like
well I'm in the Ponzi business and it's
pretty good point it didn't any of this
require any sort of like economic cases
just like other people put money in the
box and so I'm going to too and then
it's more valuable so they're going to
put more money in and at no point in the
cycle did it seem to like describe any
sort of like economic purpose so yeah
things are looking really Grim but if
you have your money locked up on FTX and
you're clinched up right now take a deep
breath
um because things look like they might
be fine although it's coming from a very
unlikely Source CZ announced only hours
after FTX paused withdrawals that they
were going to buy them binance was going
to buy FTX the number one crypto
exchange buying the number two Out quote
this afternoon FTX asked for our help
there's a significant liquidity crunch
to protect users we signed a non-binding
Loi intending to fully acquire ftx.com
and help cover the liquidity crunch now
I I'm at a loss for words this is insane
if you're not sure what's just happened
CZ basically set his competitor on fire
by stoking rumors of insolvency and then
showed up with water buckets later you
know basically acting like the hero
saving the day he just bought FTX out
for likely Pennies on the dollar in a
move that's honestly gonna go down as a
bit of business genius and also cut
throat strategy I mean this was a shark
move now in the next few months you're
going to see SBF and CZ try to spin this
whole thing as if there's no conflict
between them and there was never any
problems that was just a rumor but don't
believe it this beef was very real only
days ago CZ was saying that we won't
pretend to make love after divorce and
that quote we won't support people who
Lobby against other industry players
behind their backs so very much these
guys did not like each other and one of
them just won the war so the fact SBF
let himself get bought out by probably
the man he hates most in crypto just
shows you how badly they must have been
short on cash or the crypto that was
being withdrawn I mean I promise you
they exhausted every other option in
fact reports are already coming out that
FTX was courting basically everyone in
Silicon Valley seeking more than a
billion dollars but that by mid Tuesday
the hole in their balance sheet looked
to be significantly deeper and in the
end they had to sell out to their
biggest enemy now what does all of this
mean because for one this represents a
huge centralization in the crypto space
you know everyone wants to be
decentralized well the number one buying
out the number two is sort of a big
problem if that's your goal there also
remain huge questions like how they
could have been out billions of dollars
in the first place and how exactly they
were safeguarding customer funds if
suddenly they find themselves at a
multi-billion dollar hole in their
balance sheet after people actually look
to get their money out it seems to be
yet another other lesson that you should
not trust these crypto exchanges as far
as you can throw them and that no matter
what their CEOs say about not having to
worry about anything there could be
significant liquidity crisis that
they're lying to you about and on that
note I want to remind you that this deal
is non-binding and binance can get out
if the due diligence doesn't pan out or
if they just don't want to do it so if
you're invested in FTX and didn't get
your money out when I and others started
telling you guys that they were likely
to be insolvent it's not time to relax
Finance isn't necessarily going to save
you and you should explore all your
options because your funds might still
be in danger if this deal doesn't work
out as for FTX us I have no idea what's
going on with you guys as far as I know
they just bought out ftx.com although
the deal is still pending so who knows
what's going on with that this is just a
wild end to one of the craziest weeks of
crypto World War III basically broke out
and a winner was decided the true main
character revealed himself so that's
basically it I'll see you in a bit I've
been working super hard on a big
investigation behind the scenes I'll
tell you guys more about that later but
uh just wanted to keep you up in the
loop alright see ya